directors Guillermo del Toro and Angley
good morning we have a lot to get to
this morning so and I will announce the
nominees in the first eleven of the 24
categories let's get started for Best
Original Song the nominees are earned it
from Fifty Shades of Grey manta ray from
racing extinction simple song number 3
from youth till it happens to you from
the hunting ground and writings on the
wall from Spectre for achievement is
cinematography nominees are Carol the
hateful eight Mad Max fury road the
revenant and Sicario for Best
Documentary Short subject the nominees
are body team 12 Cho beyond the lines
Claude Landsman spectres of the show a
girl in the river the price of
forgiveness and last day of freedom
for Best Documentary Feature the
nominees are Amy
cartel and the look of silence what
happened miss Simone and wonderful fire
Ukraine's fight for freedom for
achievement in costume design the
nominees are Carole Cinderella the
Danish girl Mad Max fury road and the
revenant her Chi Minh is sound editing
the nominees are Mad Max fury road the
Martian the revenant Sicario and Star
Wars The Force awakens for achievement
in sound mixing the nominees are bridge
of spies Mad Max fury road the Martian
the revenant
and Star Wars The Force awakens
for achievement in makeup and
hairstyling the nominees are Mad Max
fury road the 100 year old men who climb
out a window and disappeared and the
revenant for Best live action short film
the nominees are Ave Maria
day one everything will be okay
Alice feel-good shock and stutter for
Best Animated Short Film the nominees
are Bear story
prologue Sanjay's super team we can live
without cosmos and World of Tomorrow for
best animated feature film the nominees
are animal ISA boy and the world inside
out Shaun the Sheep movie and when
Marnie was there congratulations
stay tuned for the second part of our
announcement with Academy president
Cheryl Boone Isaacs and John Krasinski
thank you
Academy president Cheryl Boone Isaacs
and John Krasinski welcome what an
exciting morning Thank You Guillermo
anang for kicking it off John let's
continue do it for performance by an
actor in a supporting role the nominees
are Christian Bale in the big short Tom
Hardy in the revenant Mark Ruffalo in
spotlight mark Ryland in bridge of spies
and Sylvester Stallone and Creed for
performance by an actress in a
supporting role the nominees are
Jennifer Jason Leigh the hateful eight
Rooney Mara and Carol Rachel McAdams and
spotlight Alicia vikander in the Danish
girl and Kate Winslet and Steve Jobs for
achievement and visual effects the
nominees are ex machina Mad Max fury
road the Martian the revenant and star
wars the force awakens
for achievement in film editing the
nominees are the big short Mad Max fury
road the revenant spotlight and Star
Wars The Force awakens for achievement
and production design the nominees are
bridge of spies the Danish girl Mad Max
fury road the Martian and the revenant
for adapted screenplay the nominees are
Charles Randolph enade' McKay for the
big short Nick Hornby for Brooklyn
Phyllis Nagy for Carole Drew Goddard for
the Martian and Emma Donohue for room
for original screenplay the nominees are
Matt Charman Ethan Coen and Joel Coen
for bridge of spies Alex Garland for ex
machina Pete docter Meg labove Josh
Cooley and Ronnie del Carmen for inside
out Josh singer and Tom McCarthy for
spotlight and Jonathan Herrmann Andrea
burlock Ashley savage and Alan wanker
score straight out of Compton for
original score the nominees are Thomas
Newman for bridge of spies Carter
Burwell for Carol Ennio Morricone for
the hateful eight Johan Johansson for
Sicario and John Williams for star wars
the force awakens
in the Best Foreign Language Film
category the nominees are from Columbia
embrace of the serpent from France
Mustang from hungry son of Saul from
Jordan Phebe and from Denmark a war for
achievement in directing the nominees
are Adam McKay for the big short George
Miller for Mad Max fury road Alejandro G
in yari 2 for the revenant Lenny
Abrahamson for room and Tom McCarthy for
spotlight for performance by an actress
in a leading role the nominees are Cate
Blanchett in Carol brie Larson in room
Jennifer Lawrence enjoy Charlotte
Rampling in 45 years and Saoirse Ronan
in Brooklyn for performance by an actor
in a leading role the nominees are
Bryan Cranston in Trumbo Matt Damon in
the Martian Leonardo DiCaprio in the
revenant Michael Fassbender in Steve
Jobs and Eddie Redmayne in the Danish
girl and finally we are pleased to
announce the film selected as the Best
Picture nominees they are the big short
Brad Pitt Dee Dee Gardner and Jeremy
kleiner producers bridge of spies Steven
Spielberg Marc Platt and Kristi
McCaskill Krieger producers Brooklyn
Finola Dwyer and Amanda Posey
producers Mad Max fury road Doug
Mitchell and George Miller producers the
Martian Simon Kinberg Ridley Scott
Michael Schaffer and mark - producers
the revenant Arnon mil Sean Steve :
Alejandro G a yachty - Mary parent and
Keith Redman producers room ed gynie
producer and spotlight
Michael sugar Steve : Nicole Rocklin and
Bly pagan Faust producers for the
complete list of all the nominations
please visit Oscar calm and join us
Sunday night February 28th to celebrate
these incredible artists and films at
the Oscars with our host Chris Rock see
you then